welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the marbles trailer
dropping on November 10th the film's
gonna act as a sort of sequel to lots of
different MCU projects from the last
couple of years this includes One
Division Ms Marvel and of course secret
Invasion throughout this video we're
going to be going through the trailer
and also talking about the stuff in it
what you might have missed and some of
the plot leaks to add context to what's
going on because of this there will be
heavy spoilers but I'll save the more
extreme stuff until the end of the video
that will include what's apparently in
the two post credit scene so if you just
wouldn't ruin then stick around until
the end without the way a huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into the
trailer
[Music]
kill Denver's prodigal child of the
Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there I am cold
No Air
space
[Applause]
[Music]
you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
the trailer opens with a strong focus on
Carol out in Space by herself well she's
with goose but we we see her out in
space which is when she's contacted by
Nick Fury whose name pops up on her
phone biggie the ships are doing with
exotic plants which I'm guessing come
from other planets and we also see some
photos of Monica and Maria the latter is
in her Pilot's uniform whereas the one
with monikers in a newspaper clipping
detailing that she is now an astronaut
when we last Saw Monica was during the
post credit scene in one Division and
this was when she was being invited up
to saber as we know from Secret Invasion
Nick's been up there since the blip
though he did come down to deal with his
scroll problem now in case you don't
know saber's based on the Peak from the
comic switches a giant satellite
designed to give extraterrestrial
threats away from our planet we can see
that there's a designation just below it
and this is the same one that was used
for Earth during Captain Marvel in the
comics it was actually destroyed during
secret Invasion but they've clearly
capted out the story so that Nick can go
and live there guessing that things
don't go well with his wife and guy will
end up working on there come the end of
the series but they've kept out of the
trailer to not spoil the show now both
she and Monica were hanging out at the
end of Captain Marvel's kids and I think
it would be a shame to not bring that
full circle kind of surprised they
released this when they did because they
could have easily waited until another
week but as you know Disney gonna Disney
either way there's something strange
going on in space and this involves the
hexagonal jump points that are used to
allow people to travel across the
universe when we get our first look at
saber you can see a blue one in the far
distance and there's also one directly
behind Monaco and she goes to
investigate it now this potentially ties
into a big thing from the Marvel Comics
and according to the rumors the film
will actually reveal this to be an
incursion apparently there's an earth
hurtling towards on the other side of
the barrier and this is what Monica is
going to discover in the film in case
you don't know incursions are basically
what happens when two words from
alternate universes hit each other and
if they do this then it wipes out both
universes these opposing Earths can't be
viewed by the naked eye and they can
only be seen once you pass through
what's known as an incasian wall black
panther actually did this in the comics
and this is what allowed him to see what
was happening after warning the
Illuminati they started putting plans in
place to destroy the worlds and Jonathan
Hickman strapped his secret Wars when
over the conflicts that were involved
with this now that might not be the case
here so I don't want to spend ages on it
but it is something that's important
about in mind potentially the incursion
happens which is when Monica Garza to
investigate it and then as she's
touching it the whole thing happens with
darben however with incursions you only
get an eight-hour window before the
Earth's crash so it wouldn't really give
them enough time to do everything in the
film now from the new look it seems like
touching this causes light to distort
and as we know all of the characters
powers are based around this now the
first teaser was where we got our first
look at saber and surrounding it there
were lots of different ships these
looked really similar to The Crew one at
the end of Captain Marvel and this is
where the Scrolls had been hiding at it
makes me think that the humans might
have started using Cree technology and
this is so that they can create similar
vessels as speaking of the cree we
actually have some rumors on what's
happened with the planet since the
events of Captain Marvel according to
the leaks when we last left Carroll she
actually went there and destroyed the
Supreme intelligence this is that the
power vacuum in which others have
stepped up and the leader of the planet
is now apparently darpen and the comics
darben was a Cree General and they ended
up becoming the emperor of the entire
Civilization now in Captain Marvel we
watched a younger run and the accuser
working for the intelligence and we know
what happened to him during Guardians of
the Galaxy here we have darbenu carries
an accuser Hammer not that specific one
because it was destroyed during
guardians but when you play close
attention to the footage you can also
see She carries a bangle this is sort of
gonna be the McGuffin of the movie after
being set up during the events of Ms
Marvel now that ended with a post credit
scene there apparently it actually
appears in this movie and it has Kamala
swapping places with Carol when the
post-create scene first dropped her a
lot of people thought that Kamala had
turned into Carol but we can't tell from
the first looks that they're just
swapping places every time they use
their Powers the three change with one
another which can hurt them millions of
miles across the universe when they're
close to each other they're not going to
pass off far though and thus coming
together as the safest place to be
nakamala swaps places with Captain
Marvel and she in turn goes to Monica's
Place who then in turn goes to where
Carol was from the first trailer this
looked like she was facing off against
the cree and it almost kind of ripped on
the multiversal war that Miss minutes
showed us at the start of Loki now
according to the leaks Carol was
actually trying to sneak into a peaceful
crease somehow because she doesn't
really trust their new leader.ben I feel
like Monica is gonna be who he follow
with the cree and they'll use as a
narrative way to help us learn the
backstory involving Carol now the new
trailer seems to confirm this as we see
them coming face to face and darb and
calls her the annihilator it shows her
gaining The Bangles and I'm guessing
that you'll want the full set so she can
use them to steal resources this
includes water air fire dead [__]
rainbows how do they work and this is
all gonna be in the effort to save Hala
Aladdin is meant to be in the movie as
well and later on it looks like we see
that she's stealing water from there
this is going up into a purple hex point
which could show that she can now
control these I'm guessing that the
bangle allows her to tap into these
directly which is why all the stuff with
moniker at the start happens off the
back of that as we know these hex points
allow you to travel around the Galaxy
and potentially you could move objects
from one place to another she probably
wants to come to Earth as steal all our
memes but as long as she subscribes I'm
not too bothered now they say that she's
targeting every planet they call home so
yeah that might be the reason it's Earth
and knock us the memes either way the
Bangles are extremely important and
Carol touching the portal at darb and
starts up cosmically then travels to the
hex point before it hits Kamala the
Marvels are all coming together and this
is represented by the Marvel Studios
logo which gets their s added to it it's
an entanglement and it's all tying back
to the bangle mint now in case you don't
know yeah the negabans they actually
pull from the comics and in these
Captain Marvel had them and used them as
a way to swap places with Rick Jones
this allowed them to swap places between
our universe and the Negative Zone and
the idea of swapping is of course
happening with the three here now Marvel
actually died of cancer in the comics
and Photon at this point took the name
for herself behind the scenes this was
because Marvel wanted to retain the
rights to it because Daisy of course had
their own version in Shazam a Carl
Danvers in the comics became Miss Marvel
and then she eventually took over the
Monica from Monika which made Kamala Ms
Marvel OB oh that makes sense yeah but
either way the three all get costume
redesigns in this film with carols being
similar to one of the designs that she
had in the comics with the big star
photons takes on a sort of black and
white design like how it is in the
comics and this actually builds off the
back of the sword agents that we see in
the teaser they can be seen running
around wearing black and white and this
looks like it's sort of an evolution
from that anyway the investigations
obviously going to take us to Earth At
the beginning of the movie where the
hero Heroes will be trying to find out
what's going on there's currently an
investigation going on with the guy who
plays kamala's dad but the the less said
about that the bear [__] show over at
Marvel at the moment mate now because of
shots of Carol in her room and can see
all the poses up that were in the show
the scene was actually directed by near
decosto especially for the series and
it's being brought fully across here
he's trapped in Kamala Stan's room and
we of course have all the posters up
along with the podcast that she's been
making on her computer she also has an
Iron Man toy in the dresser on the ride
and right next to the PC we can catch a
homemade helmet the scene was of course
shown in full during the credits of Miss
Marvel and I'm guessing the whole
thing's just been pulled across similar
how we got Loki season 2 in quantumania
now we can't catch the cover of Captain
Marvel Vol 7 and also the Avengers con
one from the episode one in the series
slot baby Productions was the name of
her YouTube channel and we also see
slots studded amongst the pictures Carol
even sees sketches of her and Kamala
hugging with a sign that says Kamal and
Carol save the world make it happen
below Carol's a bit freaked out and
she's obviously gonna play a big part of
the movie and I do wonder if they're
gonna find out about her being here due
to the pager we could catch this on
Fury's desk on saber and it might be how
they know to go to kamala's house so she
of course meets Fury when she's out in
space and they're finally gonna have a
big scene at the Khan's house and I'm
guessing that there's gonna be a fight
here too when her dad opens the door you
can catch someone tied up and the house
is also smashed like it's the like
button after this video now we also get
some minor glimpses at this fight with
one of the cree trying to attack Monica
guessing that she somehow pulled these
across from the ceremony and that's how
they ended up here also it's important
to point out that this suit will change
over time going in line with the
Limitless one that she has in the comics
I also wonder if she's gonna remain
Photon and potentially her name might
change to Spectrum like how it is in the
source material it looks like they all
have one big sit down in the house and
then explain their powers and their
first trailer I had a profile of herself
and I'm guessing that this tablet
actually belongs to Nick this is similar
to what he had on graphic in secret
Invasion and in this trailer they do
slightly change it we can see that she's
reading about the bangle here but it's
clear this database has everything
mapped out we'll talk about this in the
leaks part of the video but yeah again
this is just something that you should
bear in mind she's also wearing a
t-shirt with Captain Marvel comic covers
on them showing that the heroes in this
universe have Comics made about them now
the first Captain America movie ended
with us seeing the one where Steve
punches Hitler but Bucky was missing
from it because in the MCU he was
presumed dead now you might also notice
that sitting at Nick's feet is goose who
as we know is gonna be returning for the
film in our last video I talked about
how I thought he'd been in Nick's office
the entire time but we do see from the
start of the trailer again yeah he's on
Carol's ship so after the events of
endgame she may have taken him with her
which would kind of explain what's going
on here Renee Nick be careful with that
mate you know what happened last time
you might get a nice scratched out and
it's just flirting obviously and in the
trailer we get shots of Kamala on a
cruise ship with goosu whips out its
mouth tentacles just like the first film
this actually takes its victims to a
pocket dimension in its stomach which is
where they spend the rest of their lives
in agony yay now we know from the
teasers that an army of flirkin kittens
will be running rampant and I'm guessing
they're gonna be a big part of the
finale in the comics Goose was called
Chewie as a nod to Han Solo's Infamous
co-pilot ryzinemia is a reference to Top
Gun now it's two time
I was wondering in the rain
about it very big
so I actually think the Bangles will be
destroyed in the movie and this will
leave Kamala without her heart like
Powers however at the end of Ms Marvel
we did learn that she had them in gene
like a mutation
[Music]
included for a reason because this will
lead to Kamala getting her comic Acura
powers that didn't allow her to go on
and begin rather than being tied to the
Bangles she'll be able to do that
instead and that's it
how does it feel hot as it is
at some point the group are going to go
investigating what's happening and it
looks like they're all journeying out
together in space there's actually a
really cool little detail here too when
you can see that Monica has a Nine Inch
Nails t-shirt on and this is what Carol
wore during the first movie She also
wore the Green Jacket too so I'm
guessing that these are the exact same
clothes and this is her ship this isn't
going to be good if she's just flying
about and then she warps into to Kamala
so they're gonna have to use this ship
to get around in the universe this is
when they're going to be traveling to
aladna and we know that this is the
planet because of Prince Yan appearing
in the film now according to the leaks
cow will actually be married to him and
he could say that she wanted a Ladner
[Music]
on this planet yet it's said that the
women proposed to the men and apparently
she agreed to it without knowing their
Customs which led to there being
somewhat of an entanglement now we're in
for an interesting time as everyone here
apparently speaks in rhyme but I'm not a
rapper we've heard reports that this
entire segment's gonna be a big musical
so that would make sense building off
the comics anyway we've seen what looks
like a big ceremony playing out so I'm
guessing that this is all part of that
potentially Carol could be trying to lie
low though which is why she's hiding
behind that big jellyfish headdress now
according to the leaks it's all gonna go
off in the finale with darben launching
an attack on Earth saber is meant to get
caught in the crossfire and from what we
can tell everything is probably gonna go
down there anyway we get a big battle on
the ship which is apparently what we see
happening in the teaser it's at this
point the fullertons are meant to hatch
from eggs and this is when the letters
start running wild throughout the
satellite either way it's gonna be a big
battle and I love how our points are
even swapping places with each other in
order to avoid attacks could lead to a
really create a final fight which this
teaser does actually seem to highlight
I'm guessing that we'll get all the
heroes who can't breathe in space
jumping into Escape pods and being saber
and we do get a shot where a ship goes
crashing down to NY in the cockpit you
can catch what looks like Nick Fury
along with two figures one of which
seems to be Kamala they go past the
Statue of Liberty which is back to its
original copper color and this is after
it got cleaned up for the events of no
way home after this we get a quick cut
of Kamala and can see a scroll running
behind her we also know that Carol will
be with them at some point in the movie
and I'm guessing that they're going to
be attempting to find them at home
potentially the crease summer is linked
in with the Scrolls and she might be
brokering a peace deal so that the war
completely ends they then might seek
amnesty and potentially go and live on
Hala though that is kind of a push and
maybe it's just like will you just leave
them alone well we'll try and find them
a planet now according to can we get
some toasts we actually see Carol go
Super Saiyan at the end of the movie
this is known as her binary form and it
will be when her powers are fully bumped
up to 11 making her become like her most
powerful self in the comics I'm guessing
this happens when we see her flying
through the ships though we do see at
the end that she does look normal
although they could swap it out with
other VFX because this does look a bit
dodgy now back in the day when you had
bad VFX in a trailer you'd be like oh
there could be could be tinkering and
swapping that out but yeah after some
recent movies I'm not sure that's the
case anymore either way Photon looks
like she's charging up too and we also
see that they have the accuser Hammer as
we cut to the title before ending on the
joke with goose
they're good getting close
I can't can you I got it
[Music]
as for the plot leaks if you don't know
then Now's the Time to turn off the
video the next part will discuss the
apparent post credit scenes in the film
and talk about exactly what's meant to
be in them please hit a thumbs up if
you've made it to this point of the
video and you know what huge thank you
for sitting through my annoying voice So
yeah thank you anyway the first post
credit scene reportedly has Kamala
stealing a device from Nick Fury that
acts as a database for the heroes on
Earth this allows him to keep detailed
files on everyone including their names
and addresses which Kamala then uses we
see her knocking on a house and Kate
Bishop then opens the door which is when
they come face to face the pair talk
about being Heroes and then they
apparently also bring up the fact that
Scott Lang's got a daughter too now this
is obviously teasing the Young Avengers
and the group potentially coming at some
point down the line As for the second
post credit scene that's meant to have
Monica being sucked into an incursion
that's caused at the end of the film
this takes edit the a3a which is where
we learn that Monica's mother is
actually still alive now according to
the weeks she wasn't killed by Wonder
and when the statue crushed her it just
knocked her out Maria is of course
Captain Marvel in this universe and
we're gonna learn that she's now
reforming the Illuminati now this is
gonna tease things for Deadpool 3 and
according to the leaks on that will
apparently be experiencing the 838 a lot
and Monika of course never got to say
goodbye to her mother as she died during
the time between the snap and the blip
Monica had been taken out during this
unless when she returned home her mother
had been dead for years hopefully the
pair can actually say goodbye to each
other and I think this could be a
touching way to close out the movie now
if you want to know what happens in
Deadpool 3 then definitely check out our
leaks video which will be linked on
screen at the end of the breakdown
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button to get
early access to videos every week and
honestly it goes such a long way to
helping us out we also have our merch
store over at shop zeroedition.com which
sells lots of Noodie inspired t-shirts
at some more we we've just learned to
secret Invasion slash Pulp Fiction and
spy t-shirt so if you want to head over
there and help us out then the links in
the description now if you want
something else to watch check out that
Deadpool video which will be linked on
screen right now going over loads of
stuff mate it's gonna be amazing thank
you for saying through the video Yeah
appreciate it yeah I genuinely do
appreciate I don't know I'm getting
imposter syndrome a lot I don't know why
people actually watch this stuff but
yeah thanks a lot and yeah I'll see you
next time you take care yourself mate
peace